coming up on 608 on your thursday
morning boy unlv engineering students
they are creatively coming up with
solutions to everyday problems in our
bianco holmen live at their annual
competition
what's the coolest thing you've seen so
far bianca
well everything is cool nate i can't
decide they've got things that deal with
our entertainment business here in las
vegas we've got you just saw the rover
that can navigate unknown territories
and then of course we got to fill the
belly we have a project
that of course if you're interested in
growing your own products at home and
food at home i'm joined by miranda who
is a univ student so tell us the names
group members of your other the names of
your group members
so i'm miranda this is apoorva emma and
regina and we are the hydroponic kitchen
cart team all right so tell us about
this how did you come up with this idea
um actually apoorva and i lived together
and we live in a rather small apartment
and uh we wanted more kitchen space and
i wanted to grow stuff yeah plain and
simple you want to eat okay so
tell me how did you all create this how
did you all work together to create this
system
so i worked on the coding electronics
apoorva and emma worked mainly on the
internal systems with the fluids regina
worked on
the
research and component selection and we
all did testing calculations together
so this system comes with an automated
ph
sensor and adjustment system
so you'll the user will put in a sensor
and the
computer that runs the whole thing will
take measurements and put ph upper ph
down to adjust the ph so the plants can
get the right amount of nutrients yeah
that's so important you know it has to
be just right and so this is really
interesting on how it all works what
type of things can you grow
you can grow a lot of things leafy
greens are great herbs
you can even grow tomatoes in there good
no not no stock of corn though no stock
of corn it won't fit in the cart duh all
right so again these students are doing
incredible things so it's just so
amazing to see we're checking in with
one more group coming up in the next
half hour but again the engineering
students of unlv the future is in good
hands with these students here so i'm
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio